okay so the next question that i had
was do you feel like standards should go
up or down as we get older for men and
for women
go around for men and women yeah
i think
standards go up for men
as we get older
because every i say everybody a lot of
people know
that um
we have to we have to earn our value
so when we're 17 18 19 20 nobody cares
about us unless you've got game and you
just you've got it together nobody cares
um it's always women on a pedestal and
we're trying to chase them and
as you get older
the tables turn
it does turn
um so things become you are
you're more together right i've got my
house got my car got this i'm stable i
you know i've come into my own i'm going
to the gym i'm working out my lifestyle
is good so we're earning that
um
but we we're saying that even getting to
35 um once you get to 35
that's going the other way you're going
down in value
um
my options
are getting greater as i get older
they're not deteriorating when i was 19
17 18
nobody cared about my life
simple as that nobody cared as i got
older attention more attention more
attention as you get older as you get
wiser if you've got a lot more to offer
because i've got you know experiencing
this that and for
for women that is valuable
um because that's what women are looking
for
we're not running around like 21 year
olds because
that's you know we've done it
um so yeah
i think it's it's very clear that as we
get older men
our value goes up
and as females get older they have value
i'm sorry to say it goes down can i just
add to that before you move on to the
next person
one thing that i learned was
women
are born
with value yes and so when you hit 18
you find that
you're not allowed to go clubbing you're
allowed you people give you the kind of
pretty girl privilege access to things
they say that what a man on a boat has
worked his whole life to be on that boat
yeah he's had to go through the
financial trouble tax evasion all of
that to be on that boat
a beautiful woman aged 20 could be on
that same boat and they're in the exact
same place with him yeah they end up in
the same place and just to go one stage
deeper i've got two sons and a daughter
so where am i doing are you smiling
you've been on a boat
[Laughter]
i've been invited to zero boats
sorry i ain't got a boat yet anyways
except my dad's boat
so
from very young my daughter anywhere you
go oh she's so beautiful
in the shops people on the street it
doesn't happen with the boys
do you know what i mean it doesn't
happen that's how i really recognize
that oh she's cute she's this men women
children
alike and that's where their value
from that my daughter's value from when
she was born my son's yeah
he's all right exactly so
women are born with value men
have to create their values most
definitely and so that's the premise
that men
will only become value as they get older
if
they work on themselves
and actually do something
if they develop if they develop if you
don't just being older isn't enough
you have to have essential qualities
yeah
um okay i feel like in terms of men you
guys are on the right track like in
terms of like men aren't
born with value like i feel like over
time
the more like knowledge you have the
more experience you have you kind of
like
you get to a point where you're able to
have options compared to like when you
are younger
um in terms of women
i do understand what you're saying in
terms of um
you know women having um
value from the beginning you know people
coming up um women saying oh he's so
pretty having pretty privilege that's
definitely a thing i feel like
um i feel like over time
again um i feel like women still do have
experience like you do gain experience
over time
um i'm not gonna come online and say
that there's not a point where
you kind of
your value becomes less in men's eyes
i'm not going to come and say that just
know that we don't value experience
though yeah we don't value experience
females do it value experience we don't
okay that's another thing as well but um
i wouldn't say that
well me i wouldn't say it's less i
wouldn't say women become less value
i just say
in you guys that
well so not personal value we're talking
about like sexual marketplace value so
like your value in the sexual
marketplace yeah then i'd say that then
then that's kind of true then if that's
the case
um
i would say that yeah if you're talking
in terms of the sexual marketing place
then
obviously is the case
because
no one would go to a man necessarily and
say he looks pretty
but i would say in terms of
in terms of
value again i would say for both men and
women
i say for men definitely obviously as
they age
up to a certain point their value
increases i would agree with what he
said in terms of the men
with women
i would say that
the pretty privileged thing
is stops our point so there has to be
something more than the pretty privilege
which is why i disagree with the
leftover point
yeah
[Laughter]
i'll say she just totally confused me
because
if a man
when the woman is young
she's more valuable
and the older she gets sexually but her
looks start going she starts drooping
everything's just going south
whereas a man
you know you start hearing about silver
fox i mean
men can keep it up forever do you not
mean women just hang everywhere the men
are just always going to be there what's
over fox
leonardo dicaprio
i don't know you don't know silver fox
yeah teach us when you get old sexy
gray-haired man that's you know
look at most of the eligible men out
there you know and they're old they've
got their body together george they've
got their gray hair george clooney you
know and they look good
now look at him at his age and look at
the women at age now everywhere saying
that women lose their value as they get
older and men
gain more value as they get older that's
why you're going to end up with women at
35 on their own because they're losing
value so you can't say yeah i agree with
men gain value women lose value and then
disagree against the fact that when you
hit 35
your bodies match up for most of use
and then the men can still carry on
developing
they can still carry on that is why
no old man wants to sleep with an old
woman
no old man wants to sleep with an old
woman all the old men they want young
women because the men have still got it
and the women have lost it
is that why leonardo dicaprio keeps
saying when when
yes
he's like 25 too old
once it hits sunny like because he can't
he like not every guy can do that
but when you when you leave men that
have the most opportunity just like to
sleep with women they always pick a
young woman
typically except jeff bezos i don't know
what you're doing man so if you're 35
the only way you can look good date a 70
year old you're always going to look
better than a 70 year old yeah sorry i
just think it's it's good that she made
the distinction that it's the sexual
market i think that's where the
difference is if you're basing it just
on sex then
clearly then that's where the women's
value is
to a man to a man